as I've mentioned to you before each of
the three aspects of experience so the
things you know the things you don't
know and the fact of yourself
have a very ambivalent underlying
structure both positive and negative so
that the things you don't know are
interesting and compelling in the
sources of new information but also the
source of the things that undermine you
both physically and mentally and the
things you know of course your culture
disciplines you and shapes you into a
full person but also at exactly the same
time molds you and crushes you in a
particular direction rather than any of
the other directions you might have gone
in and then finally with regards to the
individual we spent a substantial amount
of time discussing the individuals
capability capacity to make order out of
chaos and and sometimes to make chaos
out of order in the service of a higher
order and that's all to the good
but just like culture and nature have
their negative aspects so did the
individual and I think personally this
is where Christian mythology in
particular comes into its own I think of
all the major religions Christianity has
the most thoroughly developed what you
might describe as formal model of evil
and that model isn't part of the
canonical writings of Christianity say
encapsulated in the Bible but part of
the cloud of sort of natural mythology
and storytelling that surrounds the
canonical writings so you could say that
although Christianity and Buddhism have
spent a substantial amount of time
developing up a representation of the
hero Christianity in particular has also
spent a substantial amount of time
developing a formal portrait of the
figure that stands in opposition to the
hero and I think the most appropriate
term for that figure who takes multiple
forms in mythology is the adversary
because the adversarial
spirit is a spirit that stands in
opposition to to everything stands in
opposition to nature stands in
opposition to culture and most
specifically stands in opposition to
that aspect of the human being that's
both exploratory and creative now the
last time we talked I had a chance to
describe to you how the figures of the
adversarial brothers emerged naturally
at the end of Genesis as a coda to the
story right Adam and Eve developed
self-consciousness they developed
knowledge of their own mortality and
death and as the primordial parents of
humanity their first children take the
form of the hostile brothers which is to
say that if you're the child of nature
and the child of culture the sort of
ultimate parents then as an individual
you take two forms a positive form and a
negative form and the negative form is
characterized in many ways by a kind of
absolute hatred of the good hatred of
the positive form and I think that you
can't understand the full human
propensity for evil without considering
more than the territoriality more than
the innate territoriality of human being
so if you look at animals well animals
are territorial and they fight to
preserve their territory and it's a
rational struggle they're fighting for
resources and for a place that they can
that they can operate and live in and
reproduce in efficiently but human
beings are substantive ly different from
that in that they're agonistic conflict
their aggression often seems to be
motivated by something more akin to the
pure desire for destruction rather than
for any rational and whatsoever and so
from that perspective I would say as an
example the fact that Hitler ended up
committing suicide in a bunker beneath
Germany's capital at the end of the
Second World War when Berlin was in
flames when all of Germany was in flames
and when his country was completely
defeated after tens of millions of
people had died in the conflict
including of course the 7 million or so
people that were killed in the Holocaust
the normal mode of interpretation of
that would be what a terrible defeat for
Hitler but an equally valid and I think
an equally valid prima facie argument
one I think that's actually more valid
is that it wasn't a defeat for Hitler at
all it was precisely what he was aiming
at right from the beginning because his
mode of being was intensely adversarial
and I would also say that it's certainly
possible that the full nature of his
motivations weren't even necessarily
clear to him as they unfolded across
time during the Second World War no more
than the full motivations of any human
being are necessarily accessible to them
as they act out whatever it is that they
act out so Carl Jung says for example
that we we act out great mythological
stories that doesn't necessarily mean
you know the story it just means you act
it out so for example you see people
whose lives are repetitive bouts of
tragedy and what they're acting out is a
tragic story and they know it insofar as
they're actually acting it out but they
don't necessarily have an explicit model
of the relationship between their
patterns of behavior and the constantly
tragic outcomes they produce well that
doesn't even necessarily mean that what
they're doing isn't voluntary because
things can be voluntary even if you
don't understand them fully there's an
aspect to the human psyche that's a nest
of vipers so to speak because you can't
necessarily trust what you see and that
means not only when you're looking at
someone else say but even when you're
looking in the mirror you can't be sure
that what you say you're doing is
exactly what you're doing your
motivations aren't transparent and they
may not even be clear
so I suppose the idea that lurks behind
this formalization is that freedom of
choice is such a good that one of its
subsidiary necessities which is that
there has to be a polar distinction
between good and evil is worth having
freedom is so important that it
justifies the distinction between good
and evil and I think that all right I
think that's a reasonable way to presume
it's reasonable to presume that that's
the manner in which experience is
actually structured and and there's
complex reasons for that one would be
that under the most optimal
circumstances which is something we'll
talk about as this proceeds to a close
that means in a sense you can have your
cake and eat it too which means the
potential existence of good and evil
allows for freedom of choice and then if
the choice is always towards the good
then you have the benefits of freedom of
choice plus the benefits of the good the
only price you have to pay is the
constant possibility of evil it's very
much like the structure of Christianity
so you have the highest God who's whose
highest son is Christ but you have the
figure of the Satan lurking in the
background who's also got a filial
relationship with the highest God it
makes for a confusing kind of theology
because in many situations of course
Christ is identified specifically with
God the Father but Satan always lurks in
the background and his his existential
status is indeterminate because since
God is everything then it's very
difficult to make the case that the evil
spirit isn't a derivative of God it's
not easy thing to get straightened out
rationally and I think Milton in
Paradise Lost is a very good attempt
makes a very good attempt to explain
exactly what this might mean how there
could be an overarching transcendent
power and there could be two subordinate
elements to that one evil and one good
without destroying the idea that God as
such is good and without eradicating the
reality of evil a very very complex
argument to make now the notion of evil
is also very very complex idea so if you
look at our arguments that support
atheism and I've mentioned some of these
like Ivan's
argument in The Brothers Karamazov where
Ivan says well the world in as such
experience as such must be evil because
it's predicated on the blood of
innocence the suffering of children the
fact that there's vast in justices in
the world is indicative that there's no
such thing as a good God or to speak in
less personified terms is evidence that
the structure of experience as such is
untenable morally it shouldn't be
because it's predicated on suffering
Jeffrey Burton Russell who's written a
whole series of books on the nature of
evil makes a very clear distinction
between different categories of terrible
events that I hit I think help bring
this into clarity so imagine this
imagine first that it's useful to make a
distinction between tragedy and evil
okay now tragedy is when the bad befalls
the good an earthquake is tragic sore
disease is tragic now it's easy to
regard a disease or an earthquake as
evil as well but the problem with that
is that doesn't seem to be any
motivation to it and so it's more likely
it's more reasonable to think something
like well people are vulnerable they
have to be vulnerable in order to give
existence a viewpoint one of the
consequences of their vulnerability is
that they're susceptible to tragedy okay
if their vulnerability is a precondition
for being then the fact that they're
susceptible to tragedy isn't necessarily
an evil it's just a consequence of their
limitation then you say well what
constitutes evil if you can't put
earthquakes and diseases and so forth
into that category well then it seems to
be something more dependent on choice
which is the argument that Iliad is
making say the world does all sorts of
terrible things to people but there are
frequent it's frequently the case that
people act in such a way to make things
worse rather than better right so if you
look at the consequences of the rise to
power of the Nazis for example doesn't
seem reasonable to put the Nazi
concentration camp in the same category
from an ethical perspective as the
earthquake right because the earthquake
is an emergent consequence of the rules
that govern physical existence whereas
the Nazi
F camp is something that was planned it
didn't have to be it seems to be an
aspect of choice and this seems to be
the idea that's lurking underneath both
this mythology and Elly a tease comment
on it it's the mere fact that the world
is terrible does not mean that it's evil
but then when you look at specifically
human actions there's this aspect of
twisted choice that fry also makes much
of he says if you if you look at the
structure of human history and you try
to explain why it has such a bloody and
terrible course it doesn't seem
sufficient just to attribute it say to
the conditions of existence or to
ignorance it seems more like there's a
force behind it so to speak manifests
say in every individual that's actually
aiming at the suffering instead of just
allowing it to happen or instead of not
stepping in to stop it but actually
aiming at it now so let's take a look at
the story it's and let's take a look at
the leading figures so we know for
example that the figure of satan and
christianity is associated with a number
of strange forms right the first
Association we know of is that he's
associated with the with the dragon in
in the Garden of Eden right so there's a
and so that there's a profound
ambivalence in Christianity about the
meaning of the opening act of Genesis
because on the one hand you have when
Adam and Eve are still profoundly
unconscious they don't suffer but
they're profoundly unconscious right
they're not self conscious they're not
aware of themselves so in many ways
they're still animals so there's a
gnostic line of speculation the Gnostics
were a Christian sect that believed that
Redemption could at least partly be
attained by understanding rather than
just faith the Gnostics believed that
the the serpent the tempted Adam and Eve
towards self consciousness was a more
developed aspect of God than the God
that had created Adam and Eve to begin
with because the unconsciousness that
characterized Adam and Eve was too
underdeveloped to be perfect and so they
had to be tempted forward into a more
fully developed consciousness and so
although classical Christianity
associated the serpent in the tree with
Lucifer who's the bringer of light who's
Satan
the Gnostic thread of reasoning said
well wait a minute it's not that simple
because yeah self-consciousness makes
you aware of death and vulnerability and
and narcs you out into the profane world
but there's an aspect of it that kind of
looks like enlightenment and you know
this already in your own lives because
often when you believe something and
you're unconsciously convinced of the
adequacy of that model and then you find
that it's not sufficient right and so
you crumble in in disappointment you put
your trust in someone and you find out
say they're not worthy of that trust and
that that the evidence that enlightens
you breaks that frame of reference and
makes you collapse you think that's a
terrible thing you can't help but feel
that as a real betrayal and as an act
even of evil but then a year later two
years later you might look back and
thank God you know I really needed that
I really needed that lesson because as a
consequence of learning that I'm much
more mature and much more likely to
establish stable relationships and so
it's easy to see that from one
perspective something can be terrible
then then from another it might not be
terrible at all and even in classic
Christianity you get this strange
ambivalence about the events in Genesis
that runs something like this well yes
it was an act of the of the most evil
spirit the spirit of enlightenment the
spirit of rationality or the bringer of
light Lucifer to knock Adam and Eve out
of their transcendental unconsciousness
and to start history it was an evil act
but on the other hand it was also the
precondition for the later emergence of
Christ and as far as the Christians are
concerned that's the greatest event in
history so without this initial opening
act right this tragic opening act
there'd be no reason for the whole
redemptive story and therefore
considered from the perspective of the
total story the opening tragedy cannot
purely be considered evil very very
complicated line of reasoning now the
other thing you see here and I think
this relates back to our initial map is
and this also helps you understand the
way people think now I said already that
it's really easy to confuse tragedy and
evil right okay so what that means is
that it's real easy to confuse the
negative
aspect of the unknown with evil and
likewise it's very easy to confuse the
negative aspect of culture with evil
your own culture the tyrannical aspect
of it or the culture of other people so
it's very easy for it for example for us
to demonize the foreigner and that's
basically because there's a part of our
mind that presumes that all things that
strike us negatively all things that
produce negative emotion on our part
like fear are the same thing so there's
a blurry category of evil that's all
terrible natural things all terrible
social things and then whatever
nastiness the individual can generate
among themselves it's much more useful
to draw a clear distinction between
these different categories because that
clarity of thought can help you can help
you focus in most specifically on those
things that the individual is
responsible for in terms of turning the
world to waste so milton says this
figure of satan lucifer the the light
bringer always associated with
rationality milton presents him as a
remarkable creature right he's the head
highest angel in God's heavenly
hierarchy his Christ elder brother in a
in a similar mythological vein he's the
most powerful angel that ever lived so
at least in the opening stages of this
act
Satan is presented as something
absolutely remarkable now the problem is
here his very remarkable nough starts to
work against him and what happens is
that as he grows in power and strength
in this heavenly hierarchy he starts to
become convinced that the omniscient
himself whatever that transcendent
figure is is unnecessary so the idea is
that whatever Satan represents decides
because of his own pride his own belief
in his own sufficiency that the
transcendent can be eradicated from
consideration and the way Milton
presents that is as a revolution in
heaven fundamentally so imagine that the
story is something like this well George
Kelly way back in like
19:55 noted that what human beings like
more than anything else really when you
get right down to it is to be right why
well it's a pain to be wrong right
because if you're wrong then the little
structure that you're using to conjure
up the world has to dissolve and then
you have to do a lot of really
aggravating work exploratory work and
creative work to put it back together
and during the time before you put it
back together then you're flooded with
negative motivational states right you
don't know which way is up
metaphorically speaking so we don't like
to be we don't like not to be right and
and so what does that mean well
psychologists know that people have a
very strong confirmatory bias which
basically means that if you bring a
frame of reference to bear on the world
the probability is very high that you
will look for confirming evidence and
you will discount disconfirming evidence
now the other thing that is
characteristic of great figures of evil
like Satan is their tendency to lie
right so Satan is Prince of the lie now
what does that mean exactly
so TS Eliot wrote this poem called the
cocktail hour he talks about this woman
who goes in for psychiatric treatment
the woman says to the psychiatrist I'm
telling you I really really hope there's
something wrong with me because I'm
having a miserable time of it and as far
as I can tell there's only two options
here either I'm okay and I'm having a
miserable time because the world is
terrible in which case there's nothing I
can do about it or there's something
wrong with me at some level of analysis
that I don't really comprehend and
although that's a painful option I'm
really hoping it's true because if
there's something wrong with me possibly
I can fix it and if there's something
wrong with the structure of the world
well what's there to do about that often
what you see in psychotherapy is a
battle between those two perspectives
going on in the minds of the client that
the client is in a situation where
they're repetitively facing tragedy they
have a specific viewpoint about the
world like the viewpoint might be well
when it comes right down to it you
really can't trust other people and then
all sorts of reasons for believing that
they were abused as children or they've
had a bad developmental history a number
of relationships that haven't gone well
they have all the facts out their
disposal to justify that particular
perspective but the truth of the matter
is is that as long as they hold on to
that belief and won't let it go and no
wonder they won't they're going to
continue to suffer and part of what
you're always doing to someone in
therapy saying you know yeah you got a
pretty coherent view of the world and
all that and I can understand why you'd
like to cram the whole world into that
coherent perspective but the truth of
the matter is as long as you hold on to
that won't sacrifice it right we'll go
through this terrible period of
dissolution it's always going to produce
the same tragic consequences so as long
as you hold on to your belief rigidly
everything around you is going to go
from bad to worse Frey says with regards
to states he says a demonic fall as
Milton presents it involves defiance of
in rivalry with God rather than simple
disobedience and hence the demonic
society is a sustained and systematic
parody of the divine one associated with
devils or fallen angels because it seems
far beyond normal normal human capacity
in its powers we read of ascending and
descending angels on Jacobs and play
those ladders and and similarly there
seem to be demonic reinforcements in
heaven life that account for the almost
superhuman grandeur of heathen empires
especially just before they fall two
particular notable passages in the Old
Testament prophets linked to this theme
are the denunciation of Babylon in
Isaiah 14 and of Tyre in Ezekiel 28
Babylon is associated with Lucifer the
Morningstar who said to himself I will
be like the Most High okay so let's
translate that into modern language and
forget about Babylon let's take the
Soviet Union for example instead and
let's say something like this I will be
like the Most High well first of all
it's not difficult to read stellen into
that from a personal perspective but
then it's more complicated than that
because you can't blame the Soviet Union
on Stalin when the Wall fell down we
know that one-third of East Germans were
KGB informers you can't blame that on
Stalin you have to blame that on the 1/3
of the East Germans who were KGB and for
right it's this this totalitarian
presupposition presumption is
distributed through the whole society
and there's a leader in a hierarchy and
all that but they're not the people to
be identified with the fact of the
totalitarian state it's distributed
through the whole society and it's
precisely this it's what I don't know I
don't need I don't need what I don't
know one of the things I really like
about this sort of Christian
metaphysical take on the problem of evil
is that it it adopts strange first
principles like if you're in him if
you're an empirical scientist it's very
difficult to come to terms with the
notion of free choice right because we
don't have deterministic models of free
choice we don't we don't know how that
might occur although it seems to be a
reasonable phenomenological observation
that if there's anything true about
existence about the facts of existence
as its subjectively construed the fact
that you seem to have the Faculty of
choice seems paramount or primary now
one might say well that's just a
delusion and we know that because our
deterministic models have been so
powerful or one might say well
alternatively we're going to presume the
subjective experience to be true and say
well our deterministic models just
aren't sophisticated enough and there's
no real reason to choose between either
of those on an a priori basis right
they're perhaps equally plausible and we
also might note from the deterministic
perspective of course that if you go
down far enough in your analysis of
physical structures down to the quantum
level se then deterministic models don't
hold at all
so determinism has its limits at the
lower end or high resolution end of
physical inquiry I have no idea what
that might mean for free choice it just
means that there are levels of analysis
that deterministic models do not
describe Christianity takes the stance
that the subjective the subjective sense
of freedom is accurate and then tries to
build the world from that point right it
presumes that's the an axiomatic
principle and so you have God in
Milton's Paradise Lost saying with
regards both to Lucifer and to human
beings who are fallen he says so will
fall he and his faithless progeny
speaking of human beings whose fault
whose but his own ingrate he had of me
all he could have I made him Justin
right sufficient to have stood though
free to fall and I like that I think
that makes a fair bit of sense to me I
started to understand this most
particularly as a consequence of reading
Carl Jung because Jung has this really
interesting notion and I think it's tied
to the idea in genesis that as soon as
Adam becomes self conscious he hides
from God so what if it was this and we
can take an evolutionary tack on this -
what if it was this what what if it was
the case that if you never turned away
from any phenomenological evidence then
you build a personality that would be
strong enough to withstand tragedy what
if that was the case so the idea here
being let's say you are the person who
notes that his or her friends don't
exactly trust trust him what do you do
well to hide away you just walk away and
then of course you never learn anything
but let's say by contrast you say well
no no the first time you get any
evidence that you're not a hundred
percent trust did you say look I got
this pang in my hearts and the
communication between you and I is not
exactly straight now something's going
on here either you haven't got your
frame of reference with regards to me
right or there's something wrong with
the way I'm looking at the world those
are the options so let's have it out
you've got this attitude and it's doing
it's hurting me tell me what you have to
say and I'll tell you what I have to say
and we'll exchange this pattern
information and as a consequence we go
both going to walk away a little bit
more well-put-together so God says yeah
yeah you know people get distorted and
twisted and bent and warped but that's
their own problem fundamentally because
they have this capacity just to turn
away and as they turn away they get
weaker and as they get weaker the world
gets worse around them because they
can't deal with it they keep making
mistakes and well that's a terrible
consequence and all that but if they
just wouldn't turn away to begin with
then there'd be no problem and there
would be no problem because the world
would stop being tragic because the
world's tragic right I mean there you
are little and vulnerable and you know
things can roll right over you the world
would never lose its tragedy but the
idea would be instead that you could
handle it without becoming corrupted and
that would be sufficient so the idea
would be it's a tough situation all
things considered but it's also an
interesting and compelling and beautiful
one and it may be that if you didn't
turn away the interesting and beautiful
and compelling aspect would overwhelm
the tragic aspect and that would be fine
you
the